welcome back to another universe sandbox
video for this video I've partnered with
the channel cheddar and they've made a
video about what would be the best-case
scenario if an asteroid were to hit
Earth you can check out their video
after this but for now I'm going to look
at a few different ways to destroy the
earth one of which will be through
asteroid impacts but later in the video
also try and see what happens if we have
a black hole in our solar system so on
the screen right now I have our solar
system it looks pretty calm right now
pretty peaceful let's go find Earth and
see what's up so here's our pretty calm
and peaceful earth now you probably know
that asteroids can cause quite a lot of
destruction to the planet and I'm going
to place a random asteroid pretty close
an orbit around the earth right now so
there's our asteroid there this is just
a random asteroid so that's going to go
around let's go have a look at him it's
called oh man and it's just going to
have I guess random stats there you can
see in there let's see how big he is
so this asteroid I let it go around 27
kilometers across
that's actually pretty big I think the
asteroid that hit the earth way back and
destroyed all the dinosaurs was about
ten kilometers across from memory so
this is actually apparently bigger than
that so I guess it's big enough to do a
lot of damage but you know against the
backdrop of the earth here he looks
pretty tiny we can see its shadow there
across the face of the earth we've got
out some mass and everything else so one
way for an asteroid to go from orbiting
around the earth to actually on a path
directly heading into the earth is for
us to set its speed to be zero
so let's find its speed here motion zero
so that's going to change things up a
bit but it's no longer got the speed to
go around but it actually starts to just
fall into the earth ok so I think he's
hit around the back here and yes sorry
so he hit around the dark side of the
earth during that so something has size
that sit out a little bit of a bit of a
hot spot there on the earth let's send
in another one and actually what should
collide so our second asteroid is about
to make an impact again on the dark side
of the earth
oh that looks nasty you saw a lot of
shockwaves I guess going out there you
know huge waves that would have
destroyed a lot of what was in this
region and you know the big thing about
the asteroid that was I guess smaller
than this one here and that caused so
much destruction that it wiped out the
dinosaurs it was because it landed in
the spot where it like displaced so much
material that it changed the makeup of
the atmosphere and the climate of the
earth and with that change in climate
life that was currently on earth
couldn't really sustain itself so even
though it's only like burned up a pretty
small patch here the impacts from that
change on the Earth's climate can be
really far-reaching alright so here was
our other asteroid that hit in the ocean
yeah both look pretty damaging we've got
an ocean hit and I think a land hit over
here it's hard to see it's nighttime
some lights are still on so we'll put
another random asteroid in orbit but
this time we'll go on and
see if we can increase the size a little
bit so that's 10 to the 16 kilograms
let's just put that up to 18 maybe a
little bit higher maybe up to the power
of 20 okay so here's a that's adjusted
it to make the radius a little bit they
get to this is our asteroid here is
probably more like a little moon he's
going around the earth his radius 283
kilometers so that's you know a lot
bigger than our previous ones which were
about 30 kilometers radius so let's see
what some of the damage he will do this
wait till he gets around to the light
side of the earth and then set his speed
his orbital speed to zero all right now
we're going in we're hitting that
interface of light and dark I think okay
so a lot more of a shockwave or a wave
of destruction coming out of that one
definitely going to have an enormous
impact on this region here where it's
actually collided
it looks like off the coast of Africa
you know not too much of a populated
region region but you saw like that
impact that was going around almost half
the earth that fiery looking impact but
of course this is going to have just a
huge impact on the climate and the
environment around around pretty much
the whole earth
so a lot of destruction from that one
there let's try one more big boy
okay let's I had another random asteroid
earth looking pretty battered at this
point so the last one was to the 20
maybe to the power 25 oh that's a bit
too big
gosh that's bigger than the earthís up
no time
no time to make him smaller that's what
earth would have Aventura that the
asteroid was so huge that it was bigger
than the earth itself don't think
there's many survivors from this one
here in fact you know this body as well
has been pretty much destroyed I don't
think well earth is completely
obliterated to dust but that's probably
fitting for this video of trying to
destroy the earth in various ways just
get yourself a real big asteroid and
that seems to do the job pretty well
well you know no one else seems to mind
too much you know the other planets
probably don't notice that earth has
been replaced by kind of an equally
sized asteroid flaming on one side
pretty menacing that there is an
asteroid that I added earlier when
trying to fiddle around with the
controls you know he also doesn't care
very much alright that was pretty
destructive but now I'm actually going
to take a fresh version of the solar
system except this one is inspired by
one of the V source videos where he
replaced the Sun with a black hole of
the same mass now if you have the same
mass of the Sun but in a black hole it
doesn't actually really change much
because the gravitational forces keeping
everything in order just depend on the
mass of that central item I guess really
so the black hole was shrunk down to a
radius of three kilometers because it's
so dense for it to have the same mass as
the Sun but at that three kilometer
radius it hasn't really had much of a
gravitational effect let's go look at
him there is a very small
he hasn't had that much effect on all
the planets going around you know life
on Earth probably would have been killed
already because most life needs the
sunlight to survive but gravitationally
like Earth is fine he's just orbiting
around curiously still has light on one
side which was interesting given that
there is
son I guess that's just the studio
lights yeah but actually you you look at
him he seems I don't know if the white
is ice but he looks pretty icy right now
so maybe the game engine can tell that
the Sun has disappeared and temperatures
are probably pretty cold over here oh
yeah
temperature of the earth that's not yes
it is temperature of the earth minus 20
degrees Celsius so without the Sun he
ain't doing so well but you know he's
still in place it's just still orbiting
around so how about we take this black
hole and make it a little bit bigger see
if that finishes off the job of
destroying earth because life is
probably apart from maybe
tardigrades have been destroyed at this
point okay so let's just click on our
black hole go to his mess instead of
being the same as the Sun we could make
it ten times our solar mass and see what
happens okay and we can see mercury
flying and they're off the usual orbit
so let's go have a look at mercury you
know she's still not at that black hole
but yeah has come in and done basically
a big slingshot around the black hole
all of these orbits now their planets
have started to be really disturbed by
the black hole just to have so much more
mass in the middle of the system it's
really going to change how things are
orbiting you know Venus is coming in
Earth is coming in too but they're all
just slingshotting around the black hole
which is in the center there no one's
really being eaten yet so let's crank
this up to 40 times the mass of the Sun
yeah yep still still got a lot of impact
there Mars is for changing Jupiter still
looks pretty chill these ones here let's
sign out increase the radius of this
black hole so
let's you know approximately double it
alright if dawn that was quick
Co sucked right and he goes Venus Mars
let's see who's left
alright so zoom out a little bit
everyone's just going on a straight
trajectory inwards I see what's happened
here when I increase the radius you know
it's it's tried to keep the density
density locked so I've tried to increase
the radius it's increase the mass hugely
to be 600,000 times the mass of the Sun
that looks like and that's given us what
ya is very powerful here and so I think
we're just going to watch people getting
gobbled right out by the black hole now
yeah there everyone goes see ya
that really shows you the power of some
of these things we're probably just
going to watch the solar system
destroyed right away I guess some some
of that mass of the Sun now is to do
with what it's gobbling up because
that's probably going to increase the
mass of it on the game I suspect if it's
adding the mass of these objects to the
mass of the black hole I feel like it
might be Jupiter oh here he comes
took a while it's traveling in on this
very straight trajectory here let's see
if we can follow him
I guess he's a bit icy as well what's
his temperature right now oh he's gone
yeah
part of the black hole now so that was
another way to destroy the earth I guess
we can watch this black hole steadily
eat more things on the menu
still a planet a few planets left to go
you know it doesn't make sense that we
would actually have a black hole instead
of a son I don't think that would happen
under any circumstance because black
holes from what I understand are created
when you have like a massive star that
goes supernova and then some part of it
collapses back in on itself because
there are so much mass there our Sun
isn't big enough to go supernova or to
eventually create a black hole but you
know our Sun will eventually expand and
change throughout its lifecycle just not
to this extent of becoming a black hole
so I guess we can be lucky that this
won't be our fate the black hole you
know maybe some of the smaller asteroids
that we saw earlier in this video I mean
I could imagine that those could be our
fate there's actually a simulation on
here showing let me find it mr. royde
there we go showing potentially
hazardous asteroids for us so let's load
this one up and this is look our solar
system and then all of the potentially
hazardous asteroids which have been
identified an asteroid is considered
potentially hazardous if the minimum
distance between its orbit and the
Earth's orbit is less than 7.5 million
kilometers and the asteroids larger than
100 meters across
okay so astronomers have currently
identified over like you know nearly
2,000 of these we can have a look at
some of them there
that's a little bit concerning you know
there's us earth mixed into the orbit of
all these different things so it's not
unimaginable and you know we shouldn't
discount asteroids for being a real risk
to earth but there are people that look
out fresh roads and there are
organizations you know trying to see
what's coming and how we can stay safe
the video over on Cheddar's channel
which I really encourage you to check
out speaks to one of these people at
NASA who is in charge of looking for
asteroids that might impact earth and
try to protect us from them so thanks
for watching this video and I hope to
see you guys next time as well as making
videos about asteroids destroying the
earth cheder are making videos that
cover business technology innovations
science and news so if that sounds like
something that you'd like consider
subscribing to their Channel and
watching some more of their videos
[Music]